ein gigantischer smiley lächelt uns aus
dem weltall zu space ex startet zweiten
landeversuch einer rakete und mehr news
von der munition rosetta diese und noch
mehr spannende neuigkeiten der vater
jetzt in den krieg zum 24
riesiger smiley im weltall wenn wir
menschen hier auf der erde in den
staaten himmel schauen lächeln und
staunen wer gerne aber wie oft kommt es
vor dass das universum uns zurück
lächelt dieser smiley wurde von judy
schmidt in den bilder datenbanken des
hubble-weltraumteleskops gefunden habe
produziert täglich unmengen an bildern
von unserem sternenhimmel auf
verschiedenen webseiten kann dann jeder
helfen diese bilder zu durchforsten das
gesicht und der mund dieses mal ist
übrigens ein ganz besonderes
physikalisches phänomen wenn
sternenhaufen besonders viel masse haben
dann entwickeln sie eine so starke
gravitation das zeit und raum um sie
herum gebogen werden
dieser sogenannte gravitationslinsen
effekt führt dazu dass sich eine riesige
linse bildet die alle objekte dahinter
vergrößert wie eine gigantische lupe das
kann sehr praktisch sein um weit
entfernte sterne zu untersuchen in
diesem fall waren es gleich zwei
sternenhaufen die in genau der richtigen
größe und entfernung die augen unseres
weltalls mileys bildeten sommer auf dem
kometen der komet 67 mio moov
gerasimenko wird ab mai sehr nah an der
sonne vorbei fliegen für zehn monate ist
er dabei so nah an der sonne dass er bis
zu 20 kubikmeter material an seiner
oberfläche verlieren soll so das
deutsche luft und raumfahrtzentrum dlr
das geschieht durch die aktivität der
sonne
wenn er an der sonne vorbei gekommen ist
wird er auf seiner elliptischen bahn
sechs jahre und fünf monate für eine
umrundung brauchen die forscher können
sich freuen zum einen werden durch die
sonnenaktivität die unteren
gesteinsschichten des kometen sichtbar
diese sind noch nicht von der
hintergrundstrahlung des weltalls
berührt worden und könnten deshalb
interessante erkenntnisse liefern zum
anderen wird die landeseinheit fiel
durch die nähe zur sonne hoffentlich
seine akkus wieder aufladen können so
dass die forscher konnten
zu ihm bekommen dragon landet sicher
nachdem das transportschiff werken einen
monat lang die internationale
raumstation iss auf ihrer umlaufbahn um
die erde begleitete ist sie nun sicher
zurückgekehrt hier in der kilometer
entfernt von der kalifornischen küste
landete das modul im mehr an bord hatte
die türken viele versuchsergebnisse und
sogar einige gegenstände die im weltall
mit einem 3d drucker gedruckt wurden
die rakete von spacex ist nun schon der
vierte versorgungsflug für die iss
nachdem die nasa ihr shuttle programm im
sommer 2011 eingestellt hatte ist die
organisation auch private unternehmen
wie spacex angewiesen
bis zum nächsten jahr sollen noch zwölf
weitere flüge für umgerechnet mehr als
eine milliarde euro absolviert werden ab
2017 soll die dragon rakete von spacex
in zusammenarbeit mit der nasa auch
personen ins all befördern
zwei raketen landeversuch ja das war
eine anstrengende woche für das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex vor einem
monat haben wir hier berichtet bei pixum
über die space extrakte die wieder auf
der erde landen sollte damals ist diese
in schieflage geraten und auf der
landeplattform im märz erstellt übrigens
lieferte genau dieser kette das dragon
modul zur iss über 60 gerade gesprochen
habe diese woche sollte nun der zweite
versuch stattfinden nachdem der stab
dreimal verschoben wurde
einmal wegen eines fehlers im
positionierungssystem und die anderen
beiden male wegen des wetters war es am
mittwoch endlich soweit um exakt drei
minuten nach sechs ortszeit startete die
rakete trotz starker winde in diesem
fall hatte die rakete jeden tag nur
einen festen zeitpunkt kein zeitfenster
zu dem sie starten konnte wenn dieser
moment verpasst wird muss mindestens
einen tag lang gewartet werden
die rakete schickte ein modul auf den
weg ins all und zwar zu einem ganz
besonderen punkt l 1 das ist der punkt
an dem sich die gravitationskräfte der
erde und der sonne gegenseitig aufheben
das modul soll starke sonnenwende
frühzeitig erkennen und die erde warnen
können
nachdem die rakete das modul auf die
reise schickte sollte der untere teil
der 40 meter hohen rakete wieder auf der
erde landen allerdings spielte das
wetter dieses mal nicht mit im meer
schlugen die wellen meterhoch eine
landung auf der plattform er schien
unmöglich aus diesem grund wurde die
weiche landung versucht dabei ist die
rakete so als ob unter ihr eine
plattform schwimmen würde gelandet
eigentlich sagt sie dabei nur ganz
leicht und langsam ins wasser doch das
war schon ein voller erfolg besonders
bei einem sturm mit einer genauigkeit
von 10 metern zum zielort st ii rakete
exakt aufrecht ins wasser was drauf hat
unternehmen spacex ist sich sicher dass
die raumfahrt durch wiederverwendbare
geben um einiges billiger wird neue
bilder von crs die raumsonde dawn hat
neue bilder vom planeten zählers
geschossen mit einer auflösung von 14
kilometern pro pixel sind es die
schärfsten aufnahmen die je von dem
himmelskörper gemacht wurden aus einer
entfernung von etwa 145 1000 kilometern
ist es den wissenschaftlern der nasa
endlich auch gelungen eine bislang
ungesehene seite des planeten
abzulichten
insgesamt konnte die raumsonde dawn eine
vierteldrehung des zwergplaneten
aufzeichnen auf den aufnahmen sind unter
anderem relativ helle flecken und einige
krater zu erkennen wie auch der koo mit
67 petroleum auf derer semenko der
mission rosetta ist der himmelskörper so
schwarz wie kohle
anfang märz soll die raumsonde dienstag
brannten cs dann erreichen und genauer
untersuchen
cas ist der größte himmelskörper im
asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter
was uns 2015 noch alles erwartet erfahrt
ihr in diesem video die top-5
fortschritte der wissenschaft dafür eben
hier oben klicken alle links zu den
angesprochenen themen gibt es in der
video schauen besonders auch hier zu den
hubble bildern da könnt ihr gerne mal
reinklicken sehr spannend zu rap und zum
block kommt es hier unten und was meint
ihr welche zeichen und gesichter sind
noch im weltall zu sehen könnte er
selber mal in den hubble bilder
nachgucken und forschen schreibt es mir
in die kommentare bis dann
bleibt dran